what's your capacity here you're here as
an author not as a union baron that's
absolutely right and i'm enjoying every
moment of it all the pressures are
lifted off me i can basically say what i
like without worrying too much about who
i'm accountable to so i'm enjoying doing
the rounds i mean your successor hasn't
come here
is that a mistake do you think no sharon
intends to do things differently in the
political arena anyone who thinks she's
not political would be making a mistake
she wants to drive politics through the
workplace and through the communities
and currently she's engaged in i think
we've got something like 20 strikes in
united and she's visiting all of those
picket lines so no she'll do things her
way
but does that mean that you know after
your era of intense political
cooperation you write about a lot of
this that you know the unions are
stepping back and concentrating more on
bread and butter issues for their
members i wouldn't say stepping back i
think it's simply that she wants to do
it differently um it's right that she
stamps her mark on unite i've been
around a long time
well she was my choice was to defeat
jared coyne and i didn't mind whether it
was sharon or steve turner who did it
and i gave her the biggest hug she's
ever had when she defeated him before he
stopped out of the office rather quickly
that's not true i'm still going in the
office every single day that was joe
pike telling lies again
um i'm in the office every day i'll
probably be physically
leaving my office at the end of october
but no sharon's very close to me she's a
force of nature and she's going to do
great now what's your
solution or argument about about lori
drivers i mean
well union you have laurie what what
what is the problem in your view well
unfortunately at the moment and i agree
with everything that john mcdonnell has
just said in your clip
kia was elected on a particular 10
pledges platform he said he would make
the moral case for socialism but above
everything else he said he wanted unity
in the party i spoke to him for one and
a half hours the day before he was
elected we knew he was going to be
elected and i told him if you want unity
you can have it everybody is desperate
for unity in the party because for five
years jeremy's getting been getting
knifed in the back and he said above
everything else that's what he would do
well look how that's turned out we've
got the most disunited party we've had
for lunch i was i was asking you about
the lorry driver's situation i'm sorry
you've got caught here
no sorry sorry the the lorry driver's
situation it's typical of the
government's being found out again we've
been saying for a long time hgv drivers
or skilled workers their rates of pay
instead of being driven down by cheap
labor need to be raised that's the issue
i mean do you think we should be opening
up to european drivers again well
they've got themselves in a mess because
of course everybody knew as soon as
brexit was triggered
that there would be a huge shortage
within this area we raised with the
government please do something invest in
skills otherwise we're going to find
ourselves in some difficulty
unfortunately they didn't listen and so
now we're in this ridiculous situation
where if there was proper investments of
course british local workers could take
up the jobs that are desperately needed
i mean it's an interesting question
your association you're
internationalists to a certain extent
so do we want
a free labor market where people can
come in and fill vacancies on building
sites only if only adam if there is
proper labor market regulations you see
the truth of the matter is and it's not
migrant workers faults they're not to
blame for anything but greedy bosses
have used migrant labor to drive down
rates of pay in terms of conditions not
the workers fault the greedy greedy
bosses and what we should have and what
we would have had with the labour
government is labor market regulations
to protect all workers that way we don't
get a race to the bottom society we have
a rate
for the job uh society looking back at
your time and again you write about it
do you feel
that at any point you ever got too
mighty sort of almost
abused your position and the resources i
don't think yourself
no i don't think so i hope not i mean
obviously people will make their own
judgments but i was the leader of the
most powerful and the most influential
union in uh the uk and ireland it's my
job to exert that influence on behalf of
our men there is this image and you see
it in the papers all the time that you
know
people union barons live high on the hog
off the back of their members well i i
don't know quite what living high on the
hog means all i know is that of course
the media always want a bogeyman i feel
that space for a period of time but my
everything i did was to make sure that
my members and the policies of my union
were influential not just with the
labour party where of course we are the
largest affiliates but also with
governance you know i've met with many
government ministers to try to persuade
them and with some of those government
ministers we did some good work and and
um
as a union baron would you like to be a
real baron member of the house of lords
no that won't happen i can state that
quite categorically i doubt very much
anybody would offer it me but i said it
hasn't been offered today
a lot of your predecessors i've
interviewed well i i certainly would be
going into the house of lords